good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy hump day hope
everyone's having an amazing day humping
someone they love that you truly truly
love that you love and trust and believe
i guess you could hum someone without
those things but it wouldn't be the same
but it hits different when you love
trust and belief
[Laughter]
how are you doing today miss cleria
[Laughter]
i'm doing great jack and i are both
wearing probably what will be the
best-selling item from our new march
truck we didn't even plan to twin we
each like we're just gonna wear merch
today because the holiday merch shops
tomorrow and we are
twins it's the toasty lights sweatshirt
every year we renew it upgrade it this
has to be my favorite i don't know if
you guys can see on youtube but the t
and the o have like sparkles in them and
you can like
feel the sparkles yeah so it's a really
special sweatshirt it comes in pink it
comes in white i'm wearing xl what are
you wearing this is an xl as well and
it's really comfortable so shop
morningchose.com tomorrow 10 a.m eastern
time usually i wear a medium these crew
necks are like the same as we usually do
i do wear a medium in them i just was
wearing yours because you know i got a
lot going on under here these days you
have nothing to explain but they are
very true to size you don't like i'm not
typically in excel yeah um so cleria is
doing well i like passed out
at 10 30 and i accidentally slept
through my alarm by 40 minutes i got 11
hours of sleep like so unintentionally
nice for you my brain was really like i
have been reciting my show back and
forth in my bedroom for four days
straight and it is exhausting like and
i'm doing it at full energy like i'm
even doing it from the beginning hello
you're not giving five percent no no i'm
giving
100
100
yet so it's mentally exhausting to be
like talking so much and i'm just really
trying to memorize it like down pat yeah
and my first kind of dress rehearsal
show is tomorrow city winery i'm so
excited to see everyone
and like i
i haven't been this nervous like in
years like for real it's exciting yes
i'd go through stages like right before
i got in the shower before like
finishing my final rehearsal last night
i was like just feeling defeated i was
like i don't know how i'm gonna memorize
this and then i played taylor's version
and i got in the shower and by the time
i got out i was like i'm going back on
tour like i was invigorated with this
zest for life it's gonna be so fantastic
obviously you're having pre-show jitters
that is so natural but i'm just i'm so
excited for everyone for tomorrow night
because you're gonna you're such a star
and thank you the world has been you
know starved to starve of your talents
on the road for the last two years
and now they will feast and i'm just
telling you like after i do i feel like
for me there's when you launch a tour i
mean i've only done it twice but there's
two enormous hurdles okay the first is
selling tickets like especially after
coba you never know like
am i still able to sell tickets like are
people gonna come do people even still
like me when you're on the internet like
you really never know you really never
know though we do get a good gauge like
yeah from this podcast so
the first hurdle will go along with your
delusion no even even if like things are
going great like you never just assume
you're going to sell out like that's
just a terrible and the nature of live
events has changed it's it's a different
ballgame it's a different ballgame so
for me my biggest hurdle always was like
i don't think i'm gonna be able to sell
tickets like the first time i did it it
was like a
fluke like so then the ticket sales went
great and i was like incredibly relieved
and then the second big hurdle is just
the first show like every show after
that gets easier and better and stronger
and tighter but the first show
i'm so nervous i'm telling you like this
weekend i'm gonna rage my face off like
i will be celebrating the fact that i
just did one show because the first is
just the hardest yeah
but i'm excited no it's really going to
be great i'm excited for you and
tomorrow is an even more exciting day
because our holiday merch collection
drops at 10 a.m eastern time at
shopmorningtoast.com we posted our
sickening photo shoot at the sickening
plaza who am i
you're the plaza you're the warehouse
and
our instagram feed you're the instagram
feed and you're soon to be people's
mailboxes literally because when you
guys get these sickening merch items
it's just gonna really you know start
the holiday season on such a positive
note
so if you want to know what we're
selling head over to the morning toast
instagram account we have a nine minute
grid yes we [ __ ] up the flow and i
wouldn't even call it like the flow's
never been worth it the flow's never
been so secondary sickening so you can
see all the products that we're selling
and also in our instagram story it's
broken out piece by piece so you can see
what is available we have ornaments sold
in a set of three we have beanies we
have a sherpa set we have robes blankets
we've never done a blanket before
blanket i actually was thinking
uh today might be a blanket day for me
there's an extra one right there i might
i might just go snuggly yeah
it's really really comfortable the robe
is so sickening
and i just can't believe the holidays
are back like we're now what is this
like our third holiday lunch
yeah it's so exciting you know how much
we love the holidays over here at the
morning toast and this collection is
more
wintery than holiday because it ain't
right to
we're non-denominational here at the
morning toast yeah no and we've done you
know
this is the tmt
blanket which is so comfortable it's
heavy like first of all it's a delicious
blanket to snuggle up with brew loves
his
but it's also like so pretty and plenty
that if you just want to like drape it
over your couch it really adds a nice
pop of plain to the room yeah so it's if
if you look on the inside obviously the
outside says tmt but the inside is like
a sherpa warm cuddle hug from your
grandmother yeah no wait really we the
inspo for the inside was brew
yeah
and do and do was the insp for the
outside he designed this blanket he said
mom we need this in the house mom let's
do a capsule collection
mom let's do a capsule collection we
have such a great show for you guys
today the fast five pump rules was on
last night
um and i watched real housewives
ultimate girls trip i was holding the
first three episodes i dropped okay i'm
like so behind on tv i know and you know
here's the thing i know you're not gonna
watch anytime soon because you have a
lot on your plate right now so i will
give you guys the high level recap no
spoilers or anything just my initial
thoughts on the concept on the group
what's happening etc so that will be in
the tv recap sound good yeah i'm just
like feeling really overwhelmed like
because of la i was behind on shows and
i haven't even turned on my tv this week
like i'm just so focused on my craft
that i'm starting to feel like
overwhelmed yeah i know that you are
dying to watch ultimate girls trip
because it's just like a cultural moment
though i do think my ultimate conclusion
is that you don't have to really yeah i
i don't know if that's a hot take it is
people are loving it
it's good we'll talk about it i'll share
all of my thoughts and we will discuss
and other than that i started a new book
last night i'm you know floundering for
book recommendations
yeah i just
what about goodreads i i went to all of
the descriptions of all of the books
that were nominated for fiction book of
the year and nothing really pulled me in
and some of them were just like too
wild in like well are you looking what
are you looking for
just like a great i'll do any genre
really you know i love what about like
another tessa bailey like because i read
another one that was so good by tessa
bailey yeah which one um i don't know
their names are so obscure yeah and they
never fit the book no i think
not not the one about the tv the
fixer-upper
no the one about the baseball player oh
i haven't even heard of it but i
actually tessa bailey has a new um like
romance book that's christmasy she does
yes and it's on my want to read it's
called
it is called window shopping oh wait let
me write that down
and it just came out october 19th but
i'm not in the christmas spirit yet so
i'm not ready to read it that was my
favorite want to read
marked it the tessa bailey one i was
talking about was
not was it fix her up yeah
did you read fix her no
yeah he's like a baseball player and
she's like a nerd it's really cute okay
fine anyways so i started rock paper
scissors by alice feeney and it it's so
far i'm in it i'm good you know
but it's just i don't know why i'm like
struggling so to find book
recommendations it's gonna be okay
i like how you won't touch my hands like
i know i literally watched them when i
came in from the outside today oh did
you yeah does that make a difference
does that make a difference uh it does
make a difference okay like when you're
being sweet with zach like will you ever
like hold his hand and kiss it like you
know how people do that i will yeah i
will hold his hand but never thought
no you don't kiss it right no i never
thought of it that's like a thing people
do like that's so sweet yeah you don't
do it no but he does that to me
of course like you kiss the hand of the
lady like you know my son i kiss ben's
hand another thing about like maybe i
should stop he's absolutely disgusting
that's so funny but you know what love
is immune
love is immune to nerve drugs like feces
and
germs bacteria yeah all the above that
is so beautiful um okay let's go let's
dive in yeah let's save and we have some
great stories and we must get into tv
recap as well so without further ado
here are the fast five stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
ship station the holidays really are the
most wonderful time of the year
a little flat at the end but if you're
running an online store you know that
they can also be the craziest times of
year you have to manage your inventory
orders to fill growing list of stressed
out customers checking in twice a day
wondering whether these last minute
gifts will arrive on time well if you
sell anything online we don't need to
tell you that shipping can be super
frustrating and there are many carriers
and a ton of factors that go into
figuring out the best rate for each
order
shipstation makes shipping the easy part
of running your business so you can get
back to doing what you're passionate
about growing your business they easily
import orders from every sales channel
whether it's amazon ebay etsy your own
website and they automate just about any
shipping task and it's all from one easy
to use dashboard change your shipping
solution can seem daunting but the
holidays are here and it's now the time
to think about making a major change so
shipstation works with fedex usps ups
all major carriers international and
local and you even get access to
discounted rates that are usually
reserved for 14 fortune 500 companies
make this holiday season a little
brighter with shipstation and use our
code toast to get a 60-day free trial
which is just enough time to handle the
holiday rush go to
shipstationshipstation.com click on the
microphone at the top and enter code
toast ship station make ship happen
great our first story some exciting news
kanye west and drake bury their beef at
dave chappelle show
kanye and drake appeared to end their
long simmering beef on tuesday night
when they showed up for laughs at a dave
chappelle comedy show in toronto i
forgot that they yeah yeah they have a
major beef kiki
do you love me the two artists who have
thrown lyrical shots at each other in
the past could be seen mugging for the
camera together on drake's instagram
account and then kanye also posted a
photo of himself drake and music
promoter jay prince on instagram with a
dove emoji to emphasize the piece made
between them connie is on this like
peacemaking journey he also made peace
with soulja boy it's so beautiful you
love to see people bury the hatchet no
like you
that it just reminds me like you've ever
been in a place that we're like you have
like so many people to apologize to like
you just make the rounds yeah that's
what connie is doing right now it's like
giving it's giving like ramona apology
tour i was just about to say that in the
apology tour continues and she takes her
talents to turks and caicos oh and she
apologizes to people she's such a big
apologizer it's crazy but you know it's
better than her being like you know the
person that she is and not apologizing
for it like at least like she
has apologized yeah you know yeah so
everyone's like they they're like the
apologies but it's like doesn't everyone
always want an apology but now it's too
much no totally
is there so much of a too much of a good
thing yeah there is but i think this is
so exciting you know
it the world nature is healing yeah for
sure i mean it definitely has crossed my
mind that like kim's single state like
maybe she would date drake i don't think
so i don't know like he's a powerful man
she's a powerful woman
they could be a powerful couple i think
that that would be just too close to
home yes and i think it would really
hurt it would hurt her relationship with
kanye you know she can pete davidson
poses like they don't run in the same
circles or anything
so
yeah and also like drake drake is just
like a funny one when it comes to
relationships like nobody wants to date
like everybody loves him every girl like
would love to but no but when it comes
down to it like nobody wants to date him
no i don't think that's it i think like
everyone wants to date him and he's just
been like
scarred humiliated i mean i would be too
if i acted the way that he did publicly
with rihanna and then rihanna like
ghosted him and was never to be heard
from again i think that definitely
scarred him from like really public
relationships i mean it was mortifying i
don't know i just feel like the women he
wants to date don't want to date like
who
just like me like
celebrities like who
rihanna can't decide do you think he
wants to date him who wouldn't i mean
that's so true who wouldn't no i feel
like he does just fine you know no i'm
sure he does like fine like but you're
right he doesn't really date celebrities
i mean was he dating serena williams for
like 45 seconds you remember that
but then like it just turned out they
had like the same manager and were
friends and they went to like a tennis
match together was it a business
yeah that was like a rumor but i don't
think it was ever truly confirmed you're
right he doesn't really date a lot of
celebrities yeah
like he has a child
i feel like he like dates his fans
that's kind of toxic i'm not gonna lie
no yeah that's actually really toxic
that's what i'm saying um well wishing
him the best and i heard there was a big
party at his house and by her i mean i
saw on instagram and you know his house
in toronto is like the sickest thing on
the planet oh yes toronto so i i'm not
i'm not sure but it sounds like
the dave chappelle show made it
somewhere to toronto yes and they had an
after party yes because i followed jeff
ross on instagram and jeff ross is on
tour this was in toronto it was where
kanye and and and he had a big party at
his house had rapper schma yeah and if
you love to see it you do you really do
nature is healing
are you ready for our next story which
is kind of crazy i'm looking forward to
hearing your thoughts page six is
reporting that w magazine is trying to
pull the travis scott and kylie jenner
cover after astroworld
w magazine is desperately trying to pull
its upcoming edition after putting
travis scott and kylie on the cover page
six has learned editors are in a tizzy
over the issue following the astroworld
festival tragedy in which 10 people died
and more than 300 were injured the scott
jenner cover which which also featured a
big interview in the issue was shot and
printed before the november 5th concert
but had not yet been shipped prompting
the scramble to recall the magazine
before it hit store shelves is it too
late w editors have cleared any plan
coverage of travis and kylie from their
website but the magazine was already
printed and now they're trying to stop
the delivery oh the trucks oh my gosh
page six they're way too late
i think so too they said in light of
what happened at azure world the
interview and cover lines seem
inappropriate to say the least 100 i
mean yeah i wonder what's on the cover
no it's so wrong it's so wrong but like
obviously
this is just
terrible timing for the magazine i mean
we've known about
this astro world thing for like almost
over a week now like yeah have they been
working on it this entire time perhaps
maybe this is just making it this is
what they've been doing since then
that's crazy i'm i mean i have to
imagine it's gonna hit the stands like i
know otherwise they just what wouldn't
have an issue for next month right and
the thing is is like i definitely think
if if they're able to they should pull
the cover but i won't hold w magazine
like you know responsible like there was
no way they could have known obviously
the timing is just horrible and it it
honestly looks bad for kylie and travis
i don't think it looks bad for w
magazine like and maybe they planted
this story being like oh now it's over
we there's nothing we can do but we want
to let you know we tried yeah yeah i
mean it's just unfortunate i don't think
it's going to be like it's unfortunate
the only way they could pull the cover
would to be not to not have a magazine a
magazine that month how much money is
lost there
and do you just
no you better rip no i don't think
companies like that can do that
that what they not have a magazine no no
no right so do you just let the cover
play out after you deal with the awkward
i think after you've tried to do every
single thing
yeah there's like nothing you can do
yeah
but even if they do stop the trucks like
they need another magazine yeah they
can't just not have an issue
yeah this sounds like episodes
yes oh my god yes yeah
okay well i do think we'll probably end
up seeing the cover and it's really
unfortunate not that i like want people
to be cancelled i just think it's like
no the hell up it's just a really bad
timing
and
it
i
now i shudder to think like what the
cover you know what what's on the cover
like no that's very outrageous yeah
america's hottest couple
like
yeah
hopefully they chose their words wisely
and wasn't like you know this killer
couple you know that's what i was
thinking yeah oh my god that would be
really bad i mean
you know
they've been like silent yeah
and they think they'll be silent
for a while that's crazy and like kind
of disappointing like
well aside from like doing what they can
to help i don't think they're going to
be going back to posting like the cars
and no no that's not what i mean when i
mean silent i mean like vocal about the
situation yeah well now it's a legal
issue and there's
there's not much that they i don't know
what they can do or say
other than layla and try and help the
families and victims as much as possible
i hope that they are yeah me as well
well that's a crazy story we'll see when
is debbie magazine hit the stands i've
never in my life purchase one i have no
idea i'd magazine timing month like so
next week the january issue drops yeah i
know it's so stupid it makes no sense
like i really like summer
it's really confusing so i don't know
when i don't know where but if you see
it just know i guess they tried to stop
it okay well the intention was i mean
the the idea that they're trying to stop
the trucks in transit like is a little
dramatic
it's an episode of the build type like
you couldn't have said it perfectly
but um
it's that's really unfortunate yeah
are we ready for our next story sure
bradley cooper is finally addressing his
pants past romance rumors with co-star
lady gaga from a star is born oh
remember when lady gaga and bradley
cooper had us wondering every day if
they were in a relationship yeah that
was really just and also the timing was
just really bad because like bradley and
irina shake like couldn't [ __ ] stand
each other yeah it was just a really
weird time and like we all kind of
believed that they were in love but then
nothing ever came to it and they weren't
in love and now bradley is confirming
that lady gaga has already said this
but now in an interview with the
hollywood reporter he's addressing the
rumors himself he when discussing the
oscar performance of shallow bradley
confirmed that they were definitely
acting so that was really the
performance like it looked like they
were falling in love on stage right yeah
he said there's a simple reason why it
looks so steamy he said quote he had
conceived the performance to unfold like
a scene from the movie in part to help
manage his own fears about singing live
he shared just from a personal
standpoint it reduces the anxiety level
he noted they kind of fall in love in
that scene in the film it's that
explosive moment that happens to them on
a stage in front of thousands of people
right it would have been so weird if we
were both on stools facing the audience
especially true he's not a singer yeah
if you tell him get up on this stage and
act right that he can do what interview
is this is he who is he talking to a
hollywood reporter
and then also lady gaga has doubled down
on her denial i like how when lady gaga
said it like nobody believed it and then
brother cooper said it we're like oh
okay you know because it did feel like
she was being coy she was or yeah but
it's also like he was someone in a
relationship yeah so she was broken up
with her feelings for him to buy into it
but in order for it to work yeah i
that's like a crazy time you're right i
totally forgot that that even happened
yeah lady gaga had said quite frankly i
think the press is very silly i mean we
made a love story for me as a performer
and as an actress of course we wanted
people to believe that we were in love
well they did a very good job they did
you know you could chuck it up to her
acting skills and the press around the
movie like really
romantic it was great marketing and had
everyone wondering
if they were
in love well i just saw an interview
lady gaga's done recently for house of
gucci and with michael strahan and he
was like well what's the best thing
that's happened to you this year she's
like i found love so she might be in a
relationship as well yeah isn't she
she's with that normie
who the guy she's dating someone i
thought like maybe they were late she
has a boyfriend who's just like a
literal businessman beau
that
what yes
unless they broke up and she's with
someone else
but she is dating i remember she was
like spotted and dating like the sound
engineer
no she's like dating this guy
what's his name michael michael polanski
yeah he's like a sound engineer he like
he does like audio
or something
he does works in like a recording studio
i think he's an entrepreneur you
remember this picture this will take you
back yeah yeah oh so they're still
together i'm assuming i never heard
anything to the contrary oh i mean i
just
okay that's great
yeah in august 2021 lady gaga and
michael plansky are in love
okay i think they're still together i
feel like this could be it
you ever like find something out
like that everyone knows that like blows
your mind that literally happened to me
yesterday like i never even thought
about it like who beanie feldstein like
was like dating but i don't know what
occurred to me to like google it and
she's dating a woman named bonnie
beanie and bonnie oh that's so cute
beanie and bonnie they should i don't
think everyone knew that
no sorry i didn't know she was a lesbian
okay so i was talk i was talking about
it with someone and i'm like who did she
date and they were like she meant this
whatever like it was like they're like
you didn't know like because i'm
supposed to know everything someone i
don't know anything something about pop
culture people feel like they've like
turned one out on me and i'm like [ __ ]
off i can only retain so much
information yeah so then i'm like oh let
me google this to see if it's true and
then i found out her girlfriend's name
was bonnie and i was like cracking up
minnie and bobby that's so cute how long
have they been together a while do you
think it's the real deal yeah she's um
bonnie is a producer and they fell in
love on set so like you know that'll do
it that'll do it because it's almost
like she found like a businesswoman no
it's it's this obviously the businessman
or the businesswoman is ideal because
a business savvy is something you know
most people money can't buy sometimes no
that acumen is hard
and when you're a star and you're
successful
you know you want love and you also want
acumen yeah but in general the formula
still works when it's one person who's a
star in front of the camera and then the
other person just has to be like a
behind a happy to be behind the camera
person and when it's a producer it's
like they chose to go into the industry
and not be a star that's beanie and
bonnie that works too i agree that's
actually let's keep our eyes on them
because that could be the potential
blueprint for a like a next great the
next great ship no well yes but also
like the next great like archetype for a
relationship like i don't know i
wouldn't call it a businessman but like
i would call it like a behind the scenes
front scenes like we have to come up
with a good word for it yeah but
but i can think okay that's like sweeter
spoon okay i was just about to say i can
think of instances where it's successful
and i can think of instances where it's
not that's like reached witherspoon yes
right her husband is like a talent
he's in the industry behind the scenes
yeah
but lady gaga christian carino okay i
just want to say like christian carino
was giving major thirst monster vibes
like he was dying to get out from behind
the camera you know what i mean
but how can that's why it's the i don't
know the perfect formula is someone
who's very comfortable being behind they
can't know these people well enough to
say i don't know i think jim witherspoon
has
proved that's just because he's the
proof in the pudding like when at the
outset i wouldn't know whether or not
well you could say the same thing about
a business man like he that he was
dating a celebrity because he wants to
be like we have to
but if he was so thirsty he wouldn't
have gotten into business
why there are plenty of business there's
a handful
but i think that's not the fast track to
fame no but i think that we can
give people the benefit of the doubt
like people who work as like producers
directors like the thing is i love
giving people about the benefit of the
doubt do you
always i feel like i'm always giving
people the benefit of the doubt okay
like truly okay
but there's something about when people
get a taste of fame that they just
[ __ ] lose their minds yes you can't
give any doubts no like everybody fails
that to like does not rise to the
challenge every single time i agree with
you that but it really does change
people you know yeah
so
that's where
it gets dicey um if i may just interrupt
you briefly to let everyone know that
today's episode is brought to you by
purevoc don't you love the dewy look of
your skin after a facial or that glow
after wearing a good face mask wouldn't
you love to have that look all day yeah
well enter pierbock a revolutionary
hybrid of skincare and makeup that
creates a natural dewy look to your skin
and helps blur imperfections that's why
they named it cover up spelled backwards
because pierbock is literally the
reverse of covering up so it's the next
hot beauty trend they're one of the
hottest beauty launches of 2021 it's
already been covered by a ton of
magazines and what their products
include are an all-day glow
multi-corrective serum a face cream and
an eye cream for a total skin
transformation i got the products and i
have to say it's one of the best ideas
on the planet because like when your
skin is in a bad spot like you have to
go to work or you have to go on a date
and like you make your skin worse by
like clogging your pores the fact that
pierbock is literal skincare but that
also lessens the look of redness like it
really really helps it's just a genius
idea and i can't believe somebody hasn't
thought of it sooner
they also really have long-term results
because you won't just get immediate
results it's real skincare packed with
over 11 active ingredients that will
deliver long-term results like radiance
even skin tone and hydration
um it's different than any other skin
care product honestly i've ever used and
i've used a lot i noticed a real
difference after the first application
and it lasted all day you're able to
leave your house without it without
makeup but also like with makeup and
still feel confident in the look of your
skin so now if you want to reverse the
cover up too with pierbock you can go to
wonderskin.com that's
dot w-o-n-d-e-r-s-k-i-n.com use promo
code toast and you'll receive 20 off
purebok or any of the amazing products
on the wonderskin site plus free
shipping with purchases over 50
that's 20 off when you go to
wonderskin.com and use promo code toast
thank you claudia it's a pleasure
next story iheartradio pledges to only
play taylor swift's re-records on its
stations wow on tuesday iheartradio the
largest radio station owner in the
country announced that it will only play
taylor's tailor version recordings on
its stations whenever taylor re-records
a new track we immediately replace the
old versions our stations will always
deliver songs that artists are eager to
share and fans want to hear said the
chief programming officer for iheart
media listeners have made it known that
they cannot wait to hear taylor's
version of each track wait that's so
crazy because i feel like radio is like
very much a part of like the music
industry like not like ever really like
advocating on behalf of artists so this
is very cool i mean i heard radio owns
like
most of the radio stations in the
country that's a really big deal they're
the biggest owner so that's pretty cool
i mean i wonder
what that actually means for other than
like you know the respect and the
kindness what does it mean for like the
masters
and what does it mean for dollars and
cents you know yeah a radio i don't
think means anything but it's just a
step in the right direction yeah and
then i guess like when it is playing on
the radio when it comes up on your
dashboard it'll say taylor's birthday
it'll say taylor's version and if you
shazam it it'll say and you'll go to
spotify yeah
yeah i mean this whole thing has got me
really really wondering about what the
value of her old masters is i feel like
with every album she releases the value
of her old masters goes down and with
things like this like it really brings
it down and i'm curious what her goal is
like is her goal to make it so that like
scooter's making no money or that
scooter wants to dump them for like a
small price and like she picks it up
like what's the goal with the old ones
or do you think she's just completely
moved past them like forgotten about
them i think the goal well the old the
first and foremost goal was like for her
to have ownership over her own music and
now she owns fearless and she owns red
and she can feel good about like having
those songs out there um
i don't know but now it's just like
the way that scooter can make money on
her
old stuff is like put in commercials put
in movies but i don't feel you know put
it on peloton but i don't feel like
they're doing anything with them i know
do you think that in order for
let's say he wanted to put it in a movie
does taylor have to approve that like it
is still technically like
she's published of the ownership right i
don't know and i feel like they can't
like sell her catalogue but no but if
she had to approve what they did with it
she could have just never approved
anything and they wouldn't make money
right so no maybe she doesn't have any
say yeah
that'd be crazy like
i wonder what i mean he's been so quiet
because he's like going through a
divorce
like what he forgot about right is that
for real yeah like what is his plan now
like
with these masters
i don't know and what are they worth
they were worth 300 million i have to
imagine they go down quite a bunch with
every album she releases yeah but
they're still she has like how many more
that she needs to do like three yeah
debut speak now 1989 and i don't think
she can re-record reputation for a while
got it
but she owns lover evermore
folklore
fearless and red now she it's five out
of nine pretty good pretty good pretty
good pretty
[Music]
pretty good fifth and final story
speaking of ownership wait sorry what
i feel like let's do like a
strip down yeah
okay
it's the final story
[Music]
for doing what's right
i think the listeners will like that me
too
fifth and final story speaking of
ownership los angeles staples center
will now be called crypto.com arena
you're lying as part of a 700 million
dollar naming rights deal jackie i swear
to god i felt like for a second i was
being pranked like this is literally a
snl sketch yep and part of a 20-year
naming rights deal the iconic downtown
la arena
known as the staples center is being
rebranded beginning christmas day its
name will be changed to crypto.com arena
according to a press release i can't
think of a worse name during the arena's
christmas day game the new logo and
indoor signage will be revealed all
external venue signage will be replaced
by june 2022 the cryptocurrency exchange
headquartered in singapore reportedly
paid 700 million dollars for the name
change just to give you guys some
context 20 years ago when staples bought
it they bought it for a hundred million
dollars wow for 20 years
i don't know it's so iconic
it's so iconic i mean this happens all
the time with stadiums and staples is
like such an old-school brand they don't
have that kind of money anymore
sometimes i hear the name of a stadium
i'm like smoothie king arena
in vegas
that's so crazy i think people will just
call this crypto arena and i think that
will stick
i mean this is the fact that they had to
say crypto.com like it's so well known
but it's like if it was called crypto
arena i'd be like who paid for this what
are we promoting but now i know
crypto.com and you know what if i'm ever
getting into crypto like i'm gonna head
to crypto.com yeah 700 million is well
spent no there is there are like so many
weird um stadium names i know i wanna
i wanna find a list to me like the good
ones are like american airlines arena
metlife stadium sounds good to me
um i don't know that many um oh oh oh oh
gillette stadium is a great name oh oh
oh oh i know it ain't i know what it is
the first time i heard gillette stadium
i thought that was kind of funny because
it's like such a consumer brand but it
really works gillette is like a cool
like gillette yeah also barclays is a
great name yeah because it's the name of
a bank right yeah okay there are some
real the 10 weirdest stadium names in
football
dick's sporting good spot
where is that in colorado okay hunky
dory's park gotta go
uh
middle fart stadium okay these are like
oh these are soccer stadiums i guess oh
no look i'm talking about branded ones
yeah pizza hut park oh my god
jobbing.com arena
easy credits to uh
oh no that's in germany hold on that is
so funny i still think the best one is
smoothie king quicken loans arena yeah
stuff like that but see when you say so
many times like i've watched like tv or
i forget what quicken loans is i've
watched so much sports with ben oh we're
back at quicken loans arena it doesn't
sound weird anymore san diego petco park
i've heard of it and actually sounds
iconic [ __ ] cute i've never heard of
that one yeah no it's a really funny
thing that like you can buy
names yeah and they just got me thinking
about like goal morning toast arena
obviously obviously okay
kfc yum is a stadium
i had heard that one i hadn't okay these
are the 12 strangest
guaranteed rate fields
kfc yum center that's so crazy why
couldn't they just call it kfc stadium
no i don't know do you think they serve
kfc yeah tony macaroni
i can't talking stick resort arena
that's where the phoenix suns play
hold on welcome stadium that's not a bad
name
um
i still i stand by my my original choice
of smoothie king center whatever you
said it was called being the weirdest
one that's just like a perfect example
of like weird brands like how does
smoothie king have enough money for
naming rights obviously not every arena
is going to be as valuable as staples
center but yeah because like the celebs
are always at staples center
if you're a touring artist like you're
the coolest ones most popular ones play
at staples center so that's great for
crypto.com you know ariana grande
spotted at kryptos.com center
same stadium center so that like if it's
here for the next 20 years like i guess
like cryptos are going to be around for
20 years yeah
at least i think it's i think it's here
to stay personally but what do i know
nothing but that's also like the nasdaq
buying
because it's a currency exchange
cryptocurrency
no i guess that's like um
sofi stadium is that
yeah is it like
i'm not even gonna protect you
you know what so far i don't know the
financial like it's an app
yes you do i'm just not saying it right
probably s-o-f-i
sophie yeah now i have no idea what
you're talking about okay it would be
like robin hood i used robin hood robin
hood stadium yeah which was probably in
our future
yeah but these opportunities only come
up once in a while because when people
buy naming rights they buy it for like
we said 20 years yeah so that's exciting
it is exciting i thought that was uh i
literally thought you were pranking me
like i couldn't believe what was coming
out of your mouth yeah it's just wild um
all right let's do the tv recap jackie
wants to talk about ultimate girls trip
which i have not seen and then we're
going to talk about last night's
vanderpump rules
which is brought to you
by bowling branch literally
tried and true okay
you can get it for yourself but you
should really it'd be nice as a gift the
gift everyone wants is a better night's
sleep bowlin branch never disappoints
with their highest quality sheets
blankets pillows and throws plus their
holiday packaging makes your gifts look
and feel special so i actually have had
bowling branch forever and i just got a
ton of new stuff i had never had throw
blankets from them before um
now everything and i got a top sheet too
i've actually been sleeping with the top
congratulations you guys she's growing
up so what i have is the signature
hemmed sheets it's their all-time best
seller they're loved for many reasons
like how they get softer with every
single wash they're buttery soft
lightweight and made with 100 organic
cotton weave that feels incredible in
all seasons yes i'm a very warm sleeper
and before bowling branch i was sleeping
with this like heavy linen
um duvet and it was just not working for
me bowling branch keeps me temperature
regulated and they're just so soft you
literally feel like you're out the four
seasons
they have a ton of different colors and
sizes they go from twin up to a
california king and their products are
completely toxin free and fair trade
certified so treat yourself and your
loved ones to the new standard embedding
from bowling branch their gifts come
wrapped and ready in their special
holiday packaging and if you order by 12
19 so that's december 19th you get
guaranteed delivery by christmas get up
to 20 off your order from november 12th
to november 17th with promo code toast
at bowlin branch dot com that's b o l l
and branch dot com promo code
toast excuse me seaside for details
exclusions may apply
enticed yeah promo code taste i love the
morning taste
okay okay oh yeah your head doesn't feel
good like i'm trying to like run an
advertisement i waited till the end and
you said this first and that opened up
the floodgates okay pump rules last
night i have to say mvp of the episode
on three no
lisa vanderpump she was being so funny
when tom came in it was like you know
that thing like from tgi fridays and
she's like i don't have anything in my
house from tgi fridays she was being
funny oh she's funny when she's when
she's not being like the worst ever
she's actually kind of funny no i'm
telling you tabula rasa with lisa
vanderpalm
yeah so like her reaction to the tom
sitting there in their glasses like
pitching nonsense was how i felt having
to watch that scene this show is really
becoming i feel like a personal attack
on me yeah
i feel like i'm in some like social
experiment where it's like how long will
this girl watch something that makes her
skin crawl yeah until she turns it off
no totally but it's hard because while
there are things that make my skin curl
there's also things that i love like
lala i think katie maloney was being so
funny but when they went to like their
restaurant with that guy like reading
their mission statement like a
funkadelic space where and they're like
this is a mission statement for our
employees you guys they're night at the
roxbury these two like i actually
i cannot and like tom sandoval is trying
he's honestly
he's trying me and i don't know how i i
watch this week after week like no i
can't recall the last time a person on
my tv like got under my skin in this way
like i it is infuriating every word that
comes out of his mouth like i'm in pain
i'm in pain i hear you but i do have to
say i actually did really think like
what tom schwartz is going through like
with his family i think a lot of people
can relate to that like during the
pandemic like your family members losing
their jobs and like wanting to help
wanting to do your own like grow your
business it just makes everything tom
sandoval's doing even more out of touch
tom sandoval is like spending all of
this money he has no out of care in the
world 1700 sconces and like tom schwartz
is really struggling and like this is a
business for him like
it just highlights how frivolous and out
of touch tom sandoval is especially as
it pertains to like starting a business
you just start with the 1700 sconces you
know and so and the fact that at either
tom sandovals knows that schwartz is
going through it and is still buying the
sconces or schwartz doesn't feel like he
can tell his best friend like what's
really weighing on him that was it was
really sad for me like i felt like i i
felt like i understood what he was
saying and it made this whole restaurant
endeavor seemed so stupid like you're on
a hit show you're making a lot of money
per episode you have a
steak in a restaurant that you don't
have to do anything for like just enjoy
that like send money back to your family
like that's more than enough money like
i feel like this mortgage alone like
it's such a bad idea like and i know
we're happy watching something that
happened a year ago so i don't know
where they ended up but i'm like
screaming at him like shut down this
restaurant before you get yourself into
a hole that you cannot get out of yeah
like and just the fact that it's called
schwartz and sandy's and tom sandoval's
at the helm like this is a recipe for
disaster not a business person like he's
not
he has no business and now he's focusing
on his music career as we reported
yesterday like what about the restaurant
if anything if if tom schwartz wants to
expand
his business like talk to lisa about tom
tom and vegas yeah like the time in new
york no i think tom sandoval and you
have to imagine every decision that they
make as a duo is tom sandoval's decision
i think he's like so desperate to get
out from under like the the helm of lisa
like really own his own restaurant which
like who the [ __ ] would want to do that
you know how hard it is to own and run a
restaurant and like lisa's got it down
pat and she just forked over 10 like
that's the dream and yeah take one to
vegas a hundred percent to atlantic city
a hundred percent and also like
restaurants are mostly unprofitable like
it's not just about like turning the
lights on and the money's gonna roll in
like you pour so much money into it and
knowing that schwartz is already has so
much on his plate and so many people
that he's worried about and taking care
of it's like
it makes me really sad i was like
feeling so sad i was hurting for him and
katie is an amazing wife and amazing and
i just want to say if my
partner
had
a partnership friendship et cetera with
someone like tom sanchez so toxic who
took up really like 90 of his life like
i don't know if i could stick around
honestly and the thing is katie's really
smart and like katie runs multiple
businesses and i think first of all
they're just so [ __ ] stupid for not
letting her in like if someone wants to
work for free like why are you not like
you're so power hungry you can't let
someone write your mission statement
like that's not even that important like
they should let her help she is much
smarter than both of them put together
and
she should really step in like i just
don't think she knows how bad it is
because like i think she's so annoyed by
tom sandoval she every time she walks he
walks in the room she leaves and
therefore she doesn't really know that
like he's running them into into the
ground because who could stand to be
near him for five minutes five minutes
let alone he's in your house yeah no
it's
it was upsetting yeah i was upset but
i really do love shorts and katie and
it's just i don't know
oh i want to talk about sheena so when
they were talking about femme fatale and
i told you this because i facetimed you
sheena was like oh my why are people
talking about the fact that i was on a
show called fem vitalik now they're
gonna go google it and see my boobs
obviously i had to google it
see my boobs was really a conservative
statement gina she's in a porno she's
doing sex
she's doing sex yeah like in multiple
positions oh wow yeah
i didn't see it well you don't have to
because i did and i just want to say
like
just don't lie there's nothing wrong
with it but don't lie yeah we're not
seeing your boobs like we're seeing
everything sex acts of sex acts of sex
front back dog all of it oh wow yes wow
and then she turns out to be this killer
i watched the whole thing it was a kid
no it was like 30 seconds she's like
playing with this knife and like
rewinding all these tapes before having
sex it was bizarre um
but yeah i just thought that was an
interesting factoid also brock and
sheena like are just like
when they were doing that workout with
charlie like i was just looking at them
and i'm like how do these two people
find each other like they're so bizarre
yeah and he's just so big like i cannot
get over his eyes yeah no
it's
i guess like she still seems happy with
him and yeah i don't know i i don't have
any thoughts yet well i just thought it
was like really weird if brock like be
so nasty to lala and then be like i'm
gonna apologize to her like why don't
you just bury the hatchet when she came
to bury the hatchery because he like
it's not as
like oh i'm sorry
i told you that ever since you planted
in my head that brock watched vanderpump
rolls when he's sewing he obviously
watches southern charm too yeah he's
like wants to be quirky and now he's
gonna make a line of baby clothes from
his old shirts literally i'm good by the
way all set i will get you one though
for your baby shower thank you so much
that is really so sweet anyways per
usual for me um lala was the star of the
episode just coming in like everybody
just like wants to try and freeze her
out and she's like you know what you you
should have a show without lala yeah
good luck i'm just letting you know if
lala leaves the show
i'm done
she's the last draw for me and i really
feel like she it's crazy how like tom
sandoval's like to her you need to grow
but like in last week's episode she
spelled it out so clearly like how much
growth she's done in the last few years
like
becoming sober losing her dad having a
baby becoming a stepmom like she's a
whole new lala even the way tom
sandoval's still doing the same moronic
[ __ ] and he has the absolute goal to
tell someone else to grow up right the
way she like walks into the event and
just immediately starts like
making amends with the people who she's
having beef with like i i really i just
respect her so much i love her so much
and i know i'm also biased but like she
is that girl i'm sorry yeah every week
tom sandoval
thinks he's that girl but he is not nor
will he ever be that girl not at all but
you know who is also that girl
a little bit
who you're not gonna you don't know
where i'm going with this raquel
and her
femme fatale look yeah sickening
sickening like
so many like i'm on a new level with
raquel i've already been really liking
her this season i'm she's finding her
voice she's so sweet she's so patient
but then she showed up with that look
and that hair and i was just like oh yes
the nose job storyline like i could live
without but
she's i agree she's stepping up also the
friendship between lala and james though
no one ever understands it is actually
really sweet like yeah when she came
over with the nordstrom bag and the uggs
yeah and they were like talking about
the night before and the nose and
everything and she they're just like
they really just get along no i never
understood it for sure but i think
they're like they are both and they were
both acting in a way that was like
harmful to the other but like at the end
of the day they're just like two people
whose personalities just really mesh
like yeah they can have a conversation
it just goes on and on yeah it was
enjoyable to watch yeah and like la la
at home like i just saw you at home i
need a reality show called look at me
you gotta lie at home and everybody
knows it everybody knows it anyways each
week is just getting more and more
difficult um and like charlie's so fake
like she's sitting there every time
sandoval be like talking so much [ __ ]
about lala and like obviously she's like
afraid of lala because then lala comes
over she's like hi like are you having
fun no and also like so charlie was like
not pleased to hear that she made up
with lala because she's worried that
sheena is gonna you know go back to lala
what is the beef with
charlie and lala like there's really
nothing what because lala like didn't
understand the food stuff and and
and talked about last season about the
pasta when she said like people are fat
because they eat pasta yeah i don't know
i really don't pretend to understand
charlie and i feel like i've allotted
like
too many brain cells to the show i have
none to give charlie okay i think that's
right like i really act like she's not
on the show and it really makes it more
enjoyable
okay um all right tell me about real
housewives ultimate girls trip okay so
the premise ultimate girls trip seven
real housewives all-stars seven days in
turks and casa caicos it's only seven
days which i didn't really know they're
in like a really nice villa
obviously you know
in the beginning the first few minutes
like it was a little cringe because
they're getting on the plane and stuff
they're getting on the plane but also
they have their confessionals and like
it's interesting it's so different from
real housewives because they talk about
the fact that they are stars which i
like theresa is comparing her instagram
followers
um ramon is saying my fans want me to
get the best room i have to get the best
room and it's like really a little bit
cringe the egos are just out of control
and it's like
it's uncomfortable at times no you you
could have predicted like being putting
teresa ramona in the same room theresa
is on her absolute best behavior
she's the sweetest you're lying you
wouldn't think she's good for her of
candy so sweet no you know what because
like so
it's easy for her to be like this big
bad wolf in her franchise but like you
can't go up against ramona you can't go
up against kenya like the
kyle like no one's going to put up with
you everyone is taking a different route
to
how they're playing it out on this show
and i'm just going to explain it really
quickly um teresa's swedish that's
insane to me sweetest pie except in the
third episode she does get into a fight
with melissa because they start talking
about the origins of how melissa got on
the show and they do not agree on the
story whatsoever and theresa is still so
mean saying that like melissa was like
constantly dming andy cohen
and melissa was like no i wasn't oh my
god and they can't and it's like this is
like the
they're it's the crux of their big
they're and they connect like they
they're fine with each other as much as
they can be but they will never agree
and they just like can't address these
issues and all the other women were like
and even cynthia was like these two are
sisters they are not friends like they
do not like each other they do not get
along they don't vibe and it's so true
and it's what we've been saying they
have they respected it and they both
love joe enough to like stop the
nonsense but i don't know how melissa
puts up with it they really don't like
each other okay so teresa comes in she's
deciding to be swedish sugar and also
she's also
definitely happier in her life with
louie yeah he wrote her a card for every
day that she opens every morning like so
cute she's so wrapped up in love and
like yes love cocoon that maybe she
really is feeling sweet right now it's
also funny how she leads with that she
is a
six-time author four-time new york times
bestseller like
the other women who talk about like
their accolades like i ramona's like i
brought this like you guys have a show
because of new york
everyone thought that was a crazy thing
to say but it's it's borderline true
everyone has like their things that they
tout and for theresa it's being an
author which i did i mean her books were
really popular it's just interesting
that that's what she leads with like and
it's also facts yeah i'm fine with that
so she's coming in just she's playing it
low-key melissa and kyle are kind of
kind of coming in on the same wavelength
and they which is like we just want to
get along having fun and we want people
to like us oh i would be hanging out
with them for sure yeah they're going
about in in a really good way like we're
going to be low maintenance knew each
other before they they have
hung out before and then i'll talk about
the room situation but ultimately the
there's one room that has uh like a
queen bed and a bunk
bed the bunk is kind of big like those
queen bunks but
two people have to share a room on the
first floor
and it winds up being melissa and kyle
because they just don't want to deal
with room drop drops and also like they
are like super fun and they get along
and they like stay out late like yes so
that worked for me now ramona is coming
in on full ramona turbochargers you know
i'm such a ramona like defender but when
she goes on about the rooms like i okay
turn on her immediately okay i have a
hot take that i think i'm the only
person on the planet who's gonna say
this so on the plane there cynthia does
this like really and by the way i mean
he talks about cynthia she came in i'm
not a whole mother i'm really like my
heart is with cynthia oh really yes yes
yes so she comes in like
uh i think kenya was really worried
about like how she was going to be on
the ship and they're like where we have
each other's back on the plane cynthia
does this whole presentation are they
all on the same flight i think they all
flew from like miami and they all like
met and then they're on one so it's
seven women on one plane yes okay
cynthia does this whole presentation
about brooklyn and how this is kenny's
first time away from brooklyn oh my god
i thought you were gonna say she brought
broccoli no no no and so like we need to
help kenya cut the court it was like so
sweet and she was like and kanga has a
lot going on in her personal life the
divorce she has a court date while
they're in turks and caicos and cynthia
says and so for that reason i think
kenya should have the master
oh my god and all of the women had been
talking like in their confessionals
about like even like mauricio before
kyle left was like kyle you should tell
them that i set up the house so you have
to have the master like everybody had
their own plans for the master and then
they get to the house and they're all
like doing a tour and ramona you know
wants the best room in the house and
instead of doing that she found a subpar
room so smart a non-descript room but
like has its own bathroom has everything
you need has everything you need not the
best room by any means and might not
even be the second best just a room
that's alone not the bunk room yeah and
she gets in the bed and she gets in the
shower and it everywhere they literally
all come in while she's in the bed
they're like get up
and she's like no and so and then she
they leave and she hops in the shower so
who wants that room no by the way that
is so smart but they're
livid with her she's not being a team
player and at one point i heard someone
say while they were touring all the
rooms that ramona should be in the bunk
room and that's where i am just like she
is the oldest she this woman is 64 years
old why should she be in the bunk room
yeah and i actually think her being the
animal that she is and taking like a
subpar single room is the best you're
gonna get from ramona and you should
just be grateful i 100 agree they were
giving her so much grief over it like
for the whole day she like they went to
a dinner that night she'd also offended
other people yeah on her way
um but that was they were like so
disrespected that she did that and it's
like
she keeps saying that she deserves the
first like a room because of seniority
and i think she keeps bringing it back
to like she's been on the show the
longest
but for me it's like a 64 year old woman
deserves to be comfortable in her room
i'm sorry like melissa is
35 like
like
ramona shouldn't be in a room with a
bunk bed that's so [ __ ] disrespectful
no i agree like it is like an age thing
and melissa i probably is the youngest
on that trip and like she can handle it
and they and they're totally fine in
there but once i need to find who said
like ramona should be in the bunk room
because they're just like so wrong so
the wrong way elder abuse i'm sorry
literally literally so anyways ramona is
just who gets the primary bedroom and
you know they never addressed who got
the master and then in the second or
third episode you just see the master
and it's kenya kenya got it okay and
also kenya is the one giving ramona the
most grief about the way she handled the
rooms and it's like wait you just got
snuck into the bed you can't you're in
the castle you can't and it's just
really like i know everyone thinks
ramona's like in the wrong but i really
don't like
sure she could have waited but no like
everybody is so mean to her they were
gonna put her in the bunk room no
totally that's not right she's an old
woman she deserves a decent room like so
anyways that's my spiel and yes she did
but then also so before they left she's
facetiming with kyle and she's like i
don't really know teresa ramona says
this i don't really know
but she's i think she's a bit of a
scarecrow if i only had a brain
oh my god
kyle tells that to melissa melissa tells
that to teresa and so like now ramona's
apologizing for something that like it
was a joke it was a joke and like
it was before this all started she's
just coming in like negative 20 points
that's so ramona but then that night
they go to um
dinner and cynthia who i just i love so
dearly
she sees ramona like the whole group is
is bonding over how awful ramona is and
ramona's really on the outside but like
it's sad but like ramona just can't even
see herself so it's like she's not a
sympathetic character but just like
everybody is like
they're so like gleeful in that they
have this thing to unite over so cynthia
pulls ramona aside and like explains to
her why all the things that she did
wrong how she could have done them right
and ramona gets it and she's like thank
you cynthia like and she comes back to
the table and she goes on her apology
tour and i think she does some great
apologies i don't know if you're making
me want to watch it or not but i really
want to watch it now okay well that's
good i'm glad i'm sharing the highlights
and it's still pretty good but there's
just something about it that's just
a little
awkward for me i i can't explain maybe
it gets better like
so there's a three episode anyways
cynthia
gets through to ramona like no one else
can ramona apologizes and everybody
tabby larassa we have seven women in the
house who are you know getting
throughout the other episodes ramona
still does her ramona things but they're
starting to understand her more and
they're also seeing the soft side of
ramona who is like this girl's girl you
know like
kyle's talking a lot about like her body
image issues and ramona's just like
pumping her up and like kyle's like tell
you there's a soft side to ramona no i
i know other people are so hard on
ramona and like
it's just it's fresh she does herself no
favor she says herself she's also an
easy target yeah
anyways
now there's um
beef between cynthia and kenya oh wow
because cynthia is really you're
supposed to really stick with the person
from your city i know the people from
each other's cities are like first of
all when ramona was going through it
luann was nowhere to be found also on
the boat one day luanne everyone's
starting to share their like their story
and they're like you probably heard it
as this but like this is what it was and
everyone has like preconceived notions
about each other and so luanne was
talking about tom
and ramona gets them from the table and
she's like i can't hear this again and
all of the women are like
why are you gonna get up your friends
opening up like blah blah and you know
luanne is about to like sugarcoat what
ramona knows no totally and it's just
like she's she can't lie in front of
ramona right so ramona excuses herself
to like get a drink and all the women
are like ramona's an animal and it's
like
i don't know like to hear luanne tell
like the tom story from a vantage point
of like
he was my drinking buddy i thought i
could change him oh god
is that what you said yes
i thought i could love the bad out of it
it's like
we all told you no literally so i
understood why ramone had to leave and
like all these girls are really acting
like mother teresa and it's like it
would be like everyone you know
having sympathy for theresa on something
that like melissa
on the issue of even them like how they
started on the show everyone is turning
on the person from their cities because
everybody is like putting themselves in
this like really glamorous glamorous
right yeah it's like not 100 true it's
not false but it's like obfuscating the
other stuff honestly it sounds good like
i'm gonna watch it i'm just like
preoccupied but i will okay
you're like in no rush and only three
episodes dropped and it is like good and
the editing it's like kind of giving me
like love island vibes i actually saw
some clips that i had the same feeling
about yeah like every time they get home
from dinner it's like housewives after
dark and it's just like them like
dancing around and drinking like
whatever um
so
kyle and melissa are getting along
really well melissa and kenya are
getting along really really well
um which is also like cynthia and teresa
are getting along really well they're at
the end theresa they have the same
energy they they say okay um and so
cynthia's now having a tough time
because kenny is kind of really bonding
with everyone kenyans was like on our
show in atlanta like i'm always the
outlier and like cynthia's bringing me
in but on this this time like everybody
wants to hang out with me and really
likes me and like i think it's just like
a different dynamic for the two of them
and cynthia's like something happened
she did one of her bailly queues and you
know when like you just
you just flip a switch and you're just
like upset and emotional and offended by
everything of course and you can't get
out of it of course cynthia can't come
get out of it and she's just like
but
but like i just have so much love for
her and um it's just
i don't know it's tough she needs to
like
put it behind her but she can't and
she's like take a nap like yeah no and i
understand not being able of course yeah
well it sounds really good i'm gonna
watch it okay so those are my thoughts
there were moments of cringe but
ultimately you know i wasn't on my phone
as much as i
could have been and it's a pretty good
setup
and the women you know it's it's good
it's good stuff it's just really
interesting to see how they like
show themselves in front you know just
it's
present themselves yeah because it's
different dynamics than them on their
own shows like the egos are just
unchecked
especially theresa
no teresa is has checked herself in at
the north on her previous show yes
unchecked no but like on this show
ramona has is running unchecked um
kenya is being kenya
and everyone else is like just trying to
like not be the villain yeah so hard um
okay cool well that is our show
right it is our show and the next time
we see you merch will have dropped it
drops tomorrow 10 a.m eastern time
shopmorningtoast.com all of the holiday
items that you see on our instagram will
be for sale we ordered a ton of stuff
but once it sells out it sells out so i
would recommend if there is something
that you want really badly set that
alarm get that merch thank you so much
for listening to the morning toast the
millennial morning show where we deliver
the past life stories that you need to
know every monday through friday on
youtube so if you're watching this on
youtube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up we're
also available as a podcast and we're
podcasts can be found so it's spotify
itunes stitch or public radio i heart
radio cast box all the places wherever
you listen to podcast find out some
morning toast and leave a five-star
review about how beautiful stunning and
smart we are
now if you made it to the end of this
episode congratulations and thank you
for being a true toaster who values what
we say and actually listens to the end
of the episode and to let us know that
you're still here why don't you go drop
a comment on our instagram post from
today and have it be the emoji of the
dove for the peace the dove peace in the
middle east
have a great day everyone we'll see you
tomorrow bye